[Musik]
es brennt auf Rhodos seit Tagen wüten
die Flammen auf der griechischen Insel
starke Winde fachen die Waldbrände immer
wieder an am Wochenende mussten
mindestens 19.000 Menschen aus dem
betroffenen Gebieten evakuiert werden
unter ihnen viele Touristen die Polizei
spricht von der größten brandevakuierung
in Griechenlands Geschichte
und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem
zdf-spezial
wir sind am 7 Tag des Feuers und es ist
immer noch nicht unter Kontrolle heißt
das auf Rhodos wir befinden uns im Krieg
sagt der griechische Regierungschef mit
sotakis auch auf Korfu müssen inzwischen
Touristen evakuiert werden und bis
Donnerstag soll es heiß bleiben bis zu
45 Grad die Menschen die vor dem Feuer
fliehen mussten sprechen von reinstem
Chaos über ein Ferienparadies in Flammen
Rhodos brennt der strandmenschen leer
und aus einem Hotel müssen hunderte
Touristen schnell raus schnell weg das
Feuer kommt immer näher aber statt
geordneter Evakuierung wird das für
viele eher eine chaotische Flucht die
Leute sind übers Meer mit Schiffen
evakuiert worden aber auch mit Bussen
und dann hieß es irgendwann das die
Busse nicht mehr fahren können weil
wegen dem Feuer und die Leute sind
japanisch geworden am Strand und haben
sich gegenseitig geschubst und wollten
halt alle auf diese Boote drauf 19.000
Menschen wurden vor den Flammen auf
Rhodos in Sicherheit gebracht laut
offiziellen Stellen eine
Evakuierungsaktion wie es sie in der
Geschichte Griechenlands noch nicht gab
allerdings funktioniert die
Evakuierungspläne alles andere als gut
wenn es überhaupt
wir wohnen nicht evakuiert unser
Nachbarhotel wurde evakuiert dadurch
haben wir es eigentlich erst mitbekommen
wir sind ca 500 km gelaufen mit
samtkoffer mit zwei Kinder ja ist den
Jungfern die Busse ausgings sind bei den
runter zum Strand der Kampf gegen die
Flammen bisher ein erfolglos die
Waldbrände sind weiter nicht unter
Kontrolle 10% der Insel sollen in
Flammen stehen Temperaturen über 40 Grad
Trockenheit Wind für die Löschtrupps die
denkbar schwierigste Situation
Verstärkung kann mittlerweile aus
Rumänien und das Slowakei und auch Korfu
brennt über 2400 Einwohner und Urlauber
wurden in der Nacht von dieser beliebten
Ferieninsel evakuiert und auch auf Korfu
ähnliches Chaos
wir kamen gestern Nachmittag an haben
dann nicht geschlafen und uns wurde
überhaupt nichts gesagt als wäre nichts
dabei war das Feuer schon direkt hinter
unserem Hotel
die Feuer wüten weiter von noch drei
schwierigen Tagen für sein Land spricht
griechenlandsministerpräsident mit
sotakis und ob danach wirklich alles
wieder wie immer ist kaum vorstellbar in
diesem Sommer
und in Berlin spreche ich jetzt mit dem
Pressesprecher der TUI ARGE dünnhaupt
guten Abend guten Abend
wir haben gesehen viele Touristen fühlen
sich von ihren Reiseveranstaltern
vollkommen allein gelassen sprechen von
chaotischen Zuständen nur nicht
vorhandene Organisation vor Ort waren
sie nicht auf seine Extremsituation
vorbereitet es sind natürlich
starke Bilder die jetzt aus Griechenland
kommen das heißt das war eine
Herausforderung die glaube ich für alle
vor Ort sowohl für die Bevölkerung für
die
Organisationen auch für die Behörden
sehr groß ist wir haben als
Reiseveranstalter glaube ich eine ganze
Menge getan es gibt auch gute Bilder
entsprechen wo wir uns vor Ort um die
Gäste kümmern das sind ja viele aus den
Hotels dann in die Unterkünfte in
Schulen und Turnhallen gekommen und
jetzt ist natürlich auch die Situation
da dass wir gucken wie wir die weiteren
Tage organisieren ja was sind denn die
größten Probleme vor Ort was raten sie
allen die sich im Moment noch auf Rhodos
oder Korfu befinden
das Gute für Korfu in dem Zusammenhang
ist sicherlich das über Nacht die
meisten schon wieder in ihre Hotels
zurück konnten das heißt auf Korfu sind
die Feuer entsprechend eingedämmt wenn
wir jetzt wieder zurückblicken nach
Rhodos dann ist die große
Herausforderung natürlich dass wir den
Menschen die jetzt in den Unterkünften
also sprich in Turnhallen sind relativ
schnell Hotelkapazitäten zur Verfügung
stellen dass die also die Möglichkeit
haben wieder auch ein ganz normales
Zimmer zumindest zu haben sich duschen
zu können
entsprechend und dass wir dann natürlich
auch schauen wie die Rückflüge
organisiert werden auf Rhodos ist ja
nicht die ganze Insel entsprechend
betroffen es gibt also größere Teile im
Norden wo die Gäste jetzt ja auch
hingehen und die Gebiete die jetzt durch
die brennende beeinträchtigt sind die
werden jetzt in den nächsten Tagen eben
auch so weit koordiniert sein dass die
Gäste dann auch ihre Rückreisen antreten
können und was sagen sie all denen die
sich jetzt trotzdem von ihrem
Reiseveranstalter allein gelassen Gefühl
also wir versuchen jeden Tag anzurufen
mit den Gästen im Kontakt zu sein das
klappt ganz gut wir sind auch in den
Turnhallen entsprechend vor Ort über 300
unserer Mitarbeiter sind auf der Insel
im Einsatz wir koordinieren aus Hannover
ich bin mir auch sicher dass die anderen
das entsprechend auch machen also den
Kontakt suchen wir sind vor Ort wir
nehmen aber natürlich auch noch die
Meldung der Gäste entsprechend auf wer
also sich noch nicht abgeholt fühlt wir
versuchen vor Ort zu sein und ich hoffe
die Gäste die spüren das auch dass wir
Ihnen da die Hilfe zukommen lassen was
heißt das jetzt für alle die
Griechenland gebucht haben und jetzt in
den Urlaub starten wollen
also für die nächsten Tage haben wir das
so organisiert dass wir keine neuen
anreisen also zumindest erstmal bis
Freitag nach Rhodos organisieren das
heißt also die Urlaube die nehmen wir
aus dem Programm geben natürlich den
Gästen die bis Freitag gebucht hätten
auch die Möglichkeit eine andere
Destination zu wählen wir wollen ja dass
die Menschen auch Ihren Urlaub den sie
sich das ganze Jahr erhofft und ersehen
haben wahrnehmen können aber wer
natürlich jetzt dort nicht hin kann der
hat die Möglichkeit entsprechend
umzubuchen und wir werden das auch in
den nächsten Tagen natürlich beobachten
anpassen weil wir wollen ja auch sicher
gehen dass die Gäste einen entspannten
Urlaub haben und wir wollen auch den
Hoteliers und den Menschen da unten auf
Rhodos die Möglichkeit natürlich geben
dass sie sich wieder neu organisieren
können weil der Tourismus für Rhodos und
für die Menschen natürlich auch sehr
wichtig ist
vielen Dank nach Berlin
von der wahrscheinlich längsten
Hitzewelle in der Geschichte
Griechenlands ist inzwischen die Rede in
praktisch allen Regionen besteht die
Gefahr von Waldbränden Griechenland ist
aber nicht das einzige Urlaubsland das
gerade mit extremen Temperaturen zu
kämpfen hat über einen Sommer zwischen
Glut Hitze und Hagel Bandit
mehrere große feuerfronten nicht nur auf
den Inseln auch auf den griechischen
Festland sind die Feuerwehren schon seit
Tagen im Einsatz doch auch viele andere
Länder im Mittelmeerraum echten unter
extremer Trockenheit und Hitze Italien
zum Beispiel auch heute wieder an die 40
Grad in Rom und in den Tagen davor war
es noch heißer
davon rausgekommen sind haben wir
gedacht wir laufen in
so einer in Madrid ist es selbst im
Schatten kaum auszuhalten einige
Touristen bereuen es mitten im
Hochsommer hierher gereist zu sein
ich würde lieber ein anderes Reiseziel
wählen oder im Winter oder Frühling nach
Madrid zurückkommen wenn das Wetter ein
bisschen besser ist als jetzt und nach
der Hitze immer wieder schwere Unwetter
in Österreich und Norditalien so heftige
Gewitterstürme das Bäume rein Weise wie
Streichhölzer umknicken
in der Lombardei verwandeln Tischtennis
große Hagelkörner die Straßen in
regelrechte Eisbahnen
in der Region Emilia Romania stehen nach
Unwettern große Flächen unter Wasser
auch Kroatiens Hauptstadt Zagreb
überflutet bei schwerem Gewittern und
Orkanböen kommen auf dem Balkan mehrere
Menschen ums Leben
überall auf der Erde zuletzt Wetter
extreme und Rekordtemperaturen zum Teil
weit über 40 Grad
der Nordatlantik fasst ein Grad wärmer
als normal und am anderen Ende der Welt
in der Antarktis so wenig Eis wie noch
nie seit Beginn der Messungen und die
Lufttemperaturen auch hier ungewöhnlich
hoch zur Zeit
extreme Wetterereignisse gehören zum
Forschungsschwerpunkt von Friederike
Otto die in London lehrt guten Abend
hallo ja was ist das jetzt gerade was
wir unter anderem in Griechenland sehen
nur ein besonders heißer Sommer oder
müssen wir uns in Zukunft auf solche
extreme weiter einstellen
das was wir in Griechenland zurzeit
sehen und auch in Spanien und Italien
ist kein besonders heißer Sommer mehr in
dem Klima in dem wir leben es ist
tatsächlich ein ja ein Ereignis das das
nicht mehr extrem oder wahnsinnig selten
ist in dem Klima in dem wir jetzt leben
aufgrund des Menschen gemacht und
Klimawandels das heißt wir müssen uns
auf alle Fälle auf solche Sommer
einstellen und auch noch auf heißere
Sommer wenn wenn ich aufhören fossile
Brennstoffe zu verbrennen
was heißt das jetzt für zukünftige
Urlaubsplanungen worauf müssen sich die
Menschen rund ums Mittelmeer einstellen
rund ums Mittelmeer wird es Temperaturen
wie dieses Jahr immer wieder geben und
wie gesagt also auch noch höhere
Temperaturen je nachdem wann wir auch
hören ja verschiedene Treibstoffe zu
verbrennen außerdem sieht man im
Mittelmeer dass die Regenfälle im Sommer
deutlich nachgelassen haben also die
Dürre Gefahr ist extrem gestiegen auch
das ist dem Klimawandel zuzuordnen das
heißt Wetter das für Waldbrände ideal
ist wird man immer mehr sehen also mit
Waldbränden muss man rechnen und wer in
welchen Regionen wird im Sommer den
künftig ganz besonders Probleme haben
wer Probleme hat im Sommer hängt davon
ab wer man ist denn also ja wenn man
reich ist in einem wahnsinnig gut
isolierten Haus auf dem Berg liegt
dann dann stört einfach gar nichts was
das Wetter angeht aber für die meisten
Menschen
sind Sommer nirgendwo mehr in Europa das
was sie mal waren also extreme
Temperaturen wird es überall geben auch
Niederschläge nehmen zu und das spüren
insbesondere Menschen die eben in
weniger gut isolierten Häusern leben das
sind Menschen die in dicht befahrenen an
Dich befahrenen Straßen wohnen denn also
die Kombination von Luftverschmutzung
durch Abgasen und Hitzewellen für also
extrem gesundheitlichen Problemen und
natürlich der die Auswirkung der dürren
auch die Landwirtschaft spüren auch all
diejenigen die es interessiert wie viel
Lebensmittelpreise also wie hoch die
Lebensmittelpreise sind
und in welchen Regionen wird das
besonders betroffen sein wir werden sich
die Sommer da verändern
in allen Regionen Europas haben wir eine
sehr sehr sehr starke Zunahme von
Hitzewellen und Hitzewellen sind heißer
als sie je gewesen sind
insbesondere im Mittelmeerraum haben wir
auch eine Zunahme von Dürren das heißt
das hat einerseits natürlich
Auswirkungen auf die Landwirtschaft wir
sehen gerade die Folgen für für
Waldbrände aber die Kombination von
Trockenheit und Hitze führt auch dazu
dass die Wasserstände in Flüssen oft
niedrig sind das heißt Transportkosten
steigen extrem in die Höhe
okay vielen dank für diese Einschätzung
für die Rike Otto
ja das war unser zdf-spezial zu den
Bränden in Griechenland mehr
Informationen dann im heutigen Journal
oder jederzeit auf der ZDF heute
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit einer
wieso Dokumentation passenderweise geht
es da auch um Urlaub und die Frage wie
nachhaltig kann der sein einen schönen
Abend noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]